good evening we are getting some more
details tonight about nevada's covet 19
vaccination plan as well as the
potential future of conventions in our
state
thanks for joining us here at five
o'clock i'm denise feldas and i'm
kirstjen joyce governor siselek wrapping
up an afternoon press conference not too
long ago
orco mana joins us live in the newsroom
with more on what the governor had to
say or come
kirsten and denise we want to first make
it clear that there is still
no vaccine for kovitt 19 right now but
governor sysolak says our state-specific
plan
outlined here is all meant to ensure
that nevada is prepared when a vaccine
becomes available
nevada dhhs submitted the plan to the
cdc about 10 days ago
at this afternoon's press conference
state health experts said
they anticipate only getting a small
number of vaccines initially
and that the distribution of the vaccine
will focus on priority populations
that includes frontline medical workers
and nevadans who have a higher risk of
exposure to the coronavirus it's
important to note that if a vaccine is
not deemed safe by the fda
it will not be released governor cesar
lack also touched on his future goals as
it relates to covet 19 restrictions
he hopes to increase capacity at
conventions to up to 50 percent by
january
1st of 2021 but the governor says
that'll only happen if we all wear masks
and practice social distancing
whether or not we get there is not a
matter of luck
it's not a matter of chance it's not a
matter we'll see what happens
it's a matter of each and every one of
you
we need the public's help and
cooperation
to make this possible the governor's
update this afternoon comes as nevada is
starting to see a coronavirus surge
governor sysolak says on saturday the
state reported over one thousand cases
for the first time since july
additionally eight counties in nevada
have been flagged for elevated disease
transmission
when it comes to our state's coven 19
vaccination plan governor sisalak and
other state health experts say it's a
living document
which means the plan is subject to
change but again there is still
no approved vaccine at this point